哈囉哈囉
這次我在歐綠的樣風狂彩購的一版
這些全部都是我花錢賣出來的大食化
就是只要無法告給大家重草變了一下
我已經放好那些是好物的那些是有大物
你這種就會打物吧
先說這個粉絲
這個它是在韓國非常非常火
地培解決跟我說
韓國化中是人手一個
那你這樣就是立馬心動
而且我買來不只一盒
抱著恨大恨大的期待
今天我買了它發現
它吃粉就算了
它一盤就是一個粉鋪硬子
就是燈本排鋪雲
用它化妝就是不停地帶個臉上蓋上
而且像什麼比意壓、眼下
這個邊邊搶下的地方
它這個根本就是進不去
還有一個是防晒
用一次這個我們們的硬圓的必口
游道季姐妹
這個還是咱們繞到走吧
再就是這個稀有質
這個就是用了之後
直接就會把我們的粉底給整般補了
我就不知道為什麼會有這麼反人類的設計
而且它是白色的
就是你如果不仔細看
你都看不出
到底在臉上系的多少油
再就是這個噴霧
這說實的話
它的這個噴頭是很細很細的
然後它保持也還可以
但是可能因為我的眼睛太敏感了
我覺得它的香味會有一點訓練進
因為我每次用蠻眼睛都是
算算的色色的
然後會出很多紅血絲
再就是這個泥膜
這個是當時二裏面膜口
它有一個非常非常大的廣告牌
而且我每近一家二裏面
就看到它的廣告牌
我以為是清潔泥膜的結構
我每次知道拿回來我才發現
它是一個
去腳真的減面
非常激烈的一個產品
當清潔泥膜就是油鍊補夠
當減面又有點太膜
而且它好像還說
定能形狀什麼的
每次用的話
你還要拿到這個燒
扣到手上
然後再把它給塗開
非常非常的美的粉
好的
帶物腳完了
再來就是咱們的這個
好物分散囉
所有的好物就太輕了
首先就是這個粉不完
我給它取名叫
幹嘛是粉膜
應該是那一面牆的粉膜裡面
最貴的
它一盒裡面是有量個
大概要130左右
這個就是我剛才用水晶十分的
然後這個是乾白的你看一下
它這個系列有很多顏色
這個綠色它就是水潤塊
就是遇到水了之後
它會變成這種軟軟弄弄的
軟綿面的樣子
非常的厚
它拍出來的那個底妝真的
就是非常的磁實非常的褲貼
還透過這個光澤感
我第二天直接沖出去
回溝了幾個小時
再來就是一個這個東西
它是一個粉底產
我只能說過有位的道理
因為我之前其實在網上
買過一把道板的
就是五塊錢買的一把
這個確實是比我買的
那個道板的也好用很多
遍遠這裏
做的非常非常的遠玩
它就可以很輕鬆的把粉底
填進我們的毛孔裡面
它也可以把粉底鋪的很薄
很均勻
配合這個MAS的粉鋪
打出來的這個底妝
就是超級超級的粉碟
接下來就是這個點硬勾
我的人生眼影
我走到哪我都會帶著它
我最喜歡的就是
它裡面的這顆紫色
它是那種
顏紫色非常非常美
就是很嫌
但是我們會嫌我們黃皮黑
這款對我來說就是很實用
因為它的顏色都是這種
比較低寶合的
我買回來就是一直願用它
像打底膚色
像握殘陰影
然後眼影
什麼打的量
這一盤通通都能搞定了
而且我最愛的一點就是
它其實顯色度不是那種特別高的
對我這種畫裝技術
不是特別好
雖然說就是很完美
我不怕它會挖錯
就是不夠我還可以別家
還有兩三紅
也是這種煙子色的
因為這次去韓國
那就是被安力到的這個色細
我去張圓陰化妝時的畫妝
適合的時候
那個老師給我用的
我馬上把這兩盤都賣了
上臉就是那種
不霧的柔柔的寒細份為感
反而就是你把它調和出來
打在臉上
真的就是又粉嫩又食
就又好看
前提就是底妝
一定要擺一點要乾淨一點
這個噴霧
我之前去看每一個美妝博度的
我裡面要是比都有它
本來我以為它就是一個
往紅產品
但是我用完發現
能當消貫
真的還是有點實力
它的這個噴頭真的就是
日系
你們敢說到嗎
噴到臉上就真的是享受
非常非常的黏密
而且味道也是不審比的
它的定妝效果
非常有的
真的幸福扣服
化妝老師那天給我用了
它我帶裝十多個小時
完全不需要不轉
一點都沒脫
而且用了它之後
出了柔臉上就是細提
還是水安靜
這個呈現力
好多好的明星的推薦
我為了買這個
六號色
我真的是跑了三四家店
這個顏色真的多的
很覺得很矩
上嘴
它是那種肉性色
非常切和我們的純色
可以把嘴巴化的很薄漫
很自然的風吹了
而且它用起來是那種
很絲滑的
還能追著我們純粥的暗沉
純粥就會看起來很乾淨
這個秋酷複猜的
如果我產品
這個是老網紅的法說
還女人手一直
這個最火的是
一號色
但是我自己試下來的話
是這個
06號色
更適合我一點
它是這種有點輕色的感覺
就在我的眼下
特別它的自然而且
它直接花一筆眼下
就噴起來了
感覺就像六筆了一樣
但是它這個有一個缺點地頭
非常容易斷
所以用它的話
得小心一些
在就是這個牌子
他們家的彩妝
我買了一堆
都還挺好用的
我就乾脆一起說了
這個
塞紅膏
它的顯色度很高
就是看起來很濃
有一樣營光
但是你先用手把它塗在
手背上
然後再用粉鋪
鋪上臉
真的是很美感
很妝的精水
直接就拿捏上了
這個
睫毛膏
它是這種
大頭刷的
隨便刷一刷了
它就是一個很濃力的效果
更跟分明的
而且它還防水也不會冰
我是那種
眼周非常非常容易冰妝
但是我用它
就是乾乾淨淨
這是兩隻眼線液比
他們加了這個眼線比
很細、很細、很好化
而且不容易妝
我買的是這個灰色和粉中色
很淡很淡的眼色
非常適合我這種大人
這個粉中色
用它來畫眼界下置
非常非常的溫柔
很自然還不會冰染
簡直就是
新機神器
超明映的放把我們雙眼
再就是這支眼線比
Lose Kiss Me的
經典就是經典
法律老的也是法律
完全的不弄墨
很順滑、很好化
完全不擁装
而且它上來眼上眼
在這中
很黑的很濃的
它在我的眼睛上
就真的跳過處
一點毛病
我再來說一個
綴好用的東西
是一瓶髮用
這個真的是
很冷門
但是真的綴綴好用
這個也是地配解決推薦的最多款
我最喜歡的就是它的味道
小爆包身
上散發出來的那種
非常的溫、非常的至於的那種味道
真的很好玩
先把它塗在手心
就是一瓶鍵
然後一把挫開
塗在頭髮上面
看起來就不會有油泥的
但是馬上頭髮上的那種毛
造就被腹皮了
目前國內都沒有什麼人在推
你們如果覺得的話
一定要試試它
這個都都貼是地配解決
暗土安泥的
紅色的這個
就是吸濃非常的強
既然都都貼上去
第二天
鬥幾個瓦就平了
我當水用完就買了10包回來
跟你們分享
噴霧的話我買了4個
這三瓶汁都比較多的
這個震宣霧的
雙錢
不水
定妝三合一的
是我
粗菜必帶的
因為我是拿他做
保持噴霧用的
很小一瓶
就是可以放在包包裡
你就要在飛進上
真的很乾
只要我感覺乾的時候
我就拿他出來
稍微的噴一下
臉就會舒服很多
而不乾燥的
保持力很持久
而且他噴出來
也真是很細密的
有一股淡淡的心鄉
這個BOG的這個噴霧
我覺得更適合日常保持不水用
就是你懶得呼呼的時候
你直接用他往臉上噴底下
然後就可以直接去剩下我早下臉
也不會覺得很乾
装錢用的話也OK
但是如果是對於牛皮來說
他做装錢
會有一點太滋潤了
再做是這個
空姐噴霧
他也是小管
這個我覺得他更適合装錢用
都他上臉吸收完
是有一點點微黏的致地
所以後續上底妝
就可以發得很勞
他的香味就是有一點濃
但是他不會去眼睛
對我還忘記說了
他是一個妝顯用的一個
是豐免吧
這個是地培典的跟我安利的
會比之前買的那些網紅管
都要好用一點
真的他的這個片
非常非常厚實
你副完眼下還可以
副那個法令管這邊
好 剩下就是這些
中文中取
就不怎麼出彩
但是你不怎麼難用